all right all you elf lovers
it's just nice to meet another human who
shares my affinity for elf culture it's
episode four of the rings of power and
so far i've seen more rings on jay-z
than in this show for those of you who
haven't seen my videos we take the
deepest of dives into the episode going
over the lore connections to the movies
and theories on what will happen next
but don't worry i save all book and
trailer spoilers until the end of the
video and i'll give you a warning when
that part comes up we're gonna get into
it make sure to like and subscribe
because here we go we begin in the court
of numenor where queen regent muriel
blesses the children that will one day
forge numenor's future but what should
be a joyous occasion is marred by the
sacred tree nimloth shedding its leaves
last episode the queen told ellendill
that the faithful believe that once a
petal falls it's a dangerous omen and a
dangerous omen it is for it precedes a
tsunami that completely destroys the
great island kingdom and if i saw that
cupboard i'd be like oh my god
this is known as the great wave for
which the episode is titled thankfully
it's all a dream but for the queen this
is but another omen that something
terrible is on the horizon down by the
builder's guild of tamar the man who got
his ass kicked by hal brand last episode
stirs up seeds of discontent spouting
treasonous words that the queen is being
poisoned by galadriel's nonsense the
numenoreans once worked hand in hand
with the elves to defeat morgoth but now
they see the elves as a threat imagine
trying to compete with a worker who
doesn't sleep tire or age it's like
trying to compete with heavy spoilers
amidst the commotion we find the
chancellor are ferrazan and his son
kevin the chancellor uses this
opportunity to get the people behind him
however i got a feeling he's more
interested in what the people think of
him than actually defending the queen
the dude even has goblets of wine at the
ready because nothing gets people on
your side better than free booze he
hearkens back to the time of elros the
first king of numenor who we saw briefly
at the hall of law he was the twin
brother of elrond who chose to live as a
mortal man he'd go on to build the hall
of laws surely the descendants of the
greatest men to live cannot be
overthrown by one elf remember that king
tar palantir was essentially overthrown
and exiled to this tower because of his
pro-elf sentiment the only reason muriel
is in power is she proclaimed not to
share her father's views kevin attempts
to woo a aryan but neither of these
characters are in the books so it looks
like the writers are spicing things up
by linking ellendill's family with our
pharazons as it appears the two will
definitely clash ellendill secretly
being pro-elf and arfarazan against
galatrial shows the queens her findings
from the hall of laws sauron is planning
a takeover of the southlands and she
wants the queen to reforge an alliance
with the elves to save the region the
queen doesn't believe any of it even
making a joke that elendil must be the
heir of a runic emperor in the books
ellendill is actually the son of one of
the lords of numenor so either they have
changed this for the show or are hiding
his noble heritage considering he knows
elvish and there's a lot more he seems
to be hiding i think it's safe to say
there's more going on here than meets
the eye with muriel unwilling to aid her
galadriel lashes out demanding to speak
to someone with real authority
i'd like to speak with the manager she
is of course referring to her father
king tar palantir this turns out to be a
terrible move as it lands her in jail
right alongside halbroon with only a few
days till his sea trials isildur is back
on the sea last episode we saw how he
was distracted by a woman's voice
calling out to him and we hear this
voice yet again with elendil telling his
son to leave the past in the past and
new information that his mother has
passed could this voice be somehow
linked to his mother isildor lets one of
the ropes slip in the hopes that he
would get kicked out of the seaguard but
it has the inadvertent effect of landing
himself and his two friends on tamo and
valadil axe too for his friends this is
the worst thing that could happen
they've been training for this their
entire lives and for them to lose this
chance because of a guy who never even
wanted to be in the sea guard in the
first place it's just further salt in
the womb back in the southlands we focus
on erendir who after last episode's
failed escape has seen him chained
awaiting the orc leader adar not much is
known about how and why an elf is
overseeing the orcs but there are some
cool things to take note of here like
where did these scars come from and why
does he go all michael jackson and wear
a gauntlet only on one hand i did
cross-reference it with the gauntlet
found in peter jackson's version and
they are different the big question here
is he salaron or not the orcs do call
him adar or father as if he's some sort
of creator and he'll later tell erendir
that he's no god at least not yet now if
you do believe he sat on one of the
biggest clues that points to this is his
time spent in valerian erendier's place
of birth during the first age sauron was
morgoth's most trusted lieutenant during
the war of belarian the war which ended
in morgoth's defeat and much of the
continent being destroyed and underwater
adar goes on to tell arender that he's
been told nothing but lies and to
untangle them would require the creation
of a new world not ominous at all
there's also this sort of odd ritual the
orcs do after a dog kills an injured orc
take note of the armor that's taken off
the orc here as it'll become important
in my spoiler section unfortunately
adar's first appearance leaves us only
with more questions than answers but he
decides to set erendere free as long as
he delivers a message to the refugees at
the elven tower at the end of episode 2
we saw bronwyn and her son theo join a
group of refugees making their way
toward this tower it's the logical place
to hole up as it has views of the
surrounding area and is somewhat
fortified but if the problem of orcs
weren't bad enough they're running low
on food theo wants to help but his
mother forbids him from going into town
and gathering supplies from waldrig's
tavern even though it's daylight and the
orcs fear the sun it's just too
dangerous so theo does what any
rebellious teen does and goes anyway now
it looks as though his town of tiraharad
is empty but when he stumbles into the
tavern he's confronted by an orc in
self-defense he takes out that blade
with the mark of sauron on it and
immediately the orc recognizes it asking
where he got it remember in episode 3
that erendier surmised the orcs were
looking for something while they dug
something that could be a weapon is this
weapon what they've been looking for we
saw in episode two that the sword
seemingly reforged itself after
collecting part of theo's blood it has
since gone back to its original form
however when theo is faced with danger
it's almost as if the sword has a mind
of its own and jabs the hilt into his
forearm allowing it to reforge itself
we'll later see waldrig have the same
marking on his forearm after all the
sword was taken from his barn so he
would have had some history with it theo
was able to make his escape and hide in
a well well well back in arizona work
has begun on that giant forge tower
after elrond secured the help of the
dwarves but there's something that just
isn't sitting right for me here it's
only been a few days since galadriel
left linden yet this forge looks like
it's at least several months into
construction just to get the material
there would take weeks is this just an
oversight by the writers or is there
some timeline trickery going on there is
a theory floating around there that
there are multiple different timelines
going on but i can't confirm that at the
moment although work on the forge is
going well calebrimbor can't help but
feel that the dwarves are hiding
something so elrond travels back to kaza
doom to visit his friend there princess
disa makes up excuses for her husband's
absence stating that he's busy at one of
the mines but elrond wasn't born
yesterday literally that guy is like
thousands of years old he sees durian
talking about making good progress in
the old mine something elrond knows is
the mind beneath mirror mirror the
fellowship passes this lake as they
leave the mines of moria it was this
lake where during the death list the
founder of kazadoom saw a reflection of
a crown above his head while looking
into it and thus built the city of
kazadoom beneath the mountains that fed
the mirror mirror so elrond snoops
around this old mine and somehow by
reciting a rhyme and hitting the wall
the door magically opens for the life of
me i don't know how elrod got himself in
here you'd think the dwarves would have
more security considering what lies
below but if you got some answers let me
know here elrond finds his good friend
durin who's none too pleased to see him
dur knows he can't hide his secret much
longer and makes elrond promise on the
memory of his father not to divulge to
anyone what the dwarves have found it's
a new ore one that is lighter than silk
but harder than iron and ore with the
potential to make the deadliest of
weaponry and armor this was that
mysterious ore king duran and the prince
saw near the end of episode 2. elrond
calls it mithril you may remember it was
a mithril vest bilbo gave to frodo in
rivendell to aid him on his journey a
vest which was gifted to bilbo by thorne
oakenshield for his services as burglar
in the hobbit elrond asks why don't the
dwarves celebrate this amazing find but
king during the third has restricted its
mining in the name of caution and speak
of the devil at the same time the mind
collapses trapping for minors there is a
brief scene between ayarian and the
chancellor's son but it really doesn't
develop the plot at all like you could
take the scene out and it wouldn't
change the episode at all back in the
delightful prison of numenor hal brown
gives galadriel some very odd advice in
order to master your opponent you must
master that which they most fear if
you're part of the contingent that
believes halbrand is some form of sauron
or perhaps one of his future nazgul this
line seems to fit that narrative
arfarazan arrives telling galadriel that
she is to be shipped back to the elves
under armed escort but galadriel easily
takes on these four armed guards locking
them in her cell and farazan is like
okay chill i'll sit this one out halbern
tells the chancellor that he doesn't
have to fight her if he knows where
she's going so i'm not quite sure what
halbrin's goal is here on the one hand
he's helping galadriel but on the other
it's implied he tells the chancellor
that she's off to see the king isildur
and aryan catch up where she finds out
he's been kicked out of the seaguard and
he finds out she wound up on a dinner
with kevin i do like the mural of men
and elves working together to take down
a sea creature i wonder if it's related
to the one we saw in episode 2. with
galadriel scaling the tower in a dress
no less we get our first glimpse of king
tar palantir the man looks like he's in
rough shape her meeting with the king is
short lived however with the
interruption of queen emirial the king
was overthrown when he proposed renewing
relationship with the elves and the
queen regent his daughter was put in his
place with the promise of quelling the
unrest on the eve of her takeover the
king showed her the palantir one of
seven seeing stones you may remember
saruman controlling one in the lord of
the rings but the queen regent is stuck
between a rock and a hard place does she
side with her father and have open
rebellion or does she ignore the vision
and risk the total destruction of
numenor so even though galadriel sees
the exact same vision of this great wave
the queen stands firm on her decision to
send her away she says faith may bind
one heart but not a kingdom which i took
to mean that the queen sides with her
but it's not enough to sway the kingdom
in essence her hands are tied theo's
friend rowan arrives back as the
famished crowd goes in a frenzy for food
the only problem is theo's left behind
and the sun has since set while he
attempts to escape he's caught by that
same orc we encountered at the tavern
and he wants to know where that blade is
but before he can find out erendier
saves the day the two of them make their
escape through the forest and even
bronwen has left the safety of the tower
in search of them with erendier's arrow
catching skills they make it into a
clearing as the morning sun offers them
reprieve from the sun hating orcs across
the misty mountains at kazadoom disa
performs a ritual pleading to the rocks
to release the bodies of the miners
should they still be alive among the
rubble what's really interesting here is
the way the rocks respond to this plea
look at the way they move almost like
the rocks and sand found in the
introductory credits princess diesel
apologizes to elrond for lying to him
about durin if it had not been for
elrond duron would have been trapped
under that rubble durian arrives with
good news all four miners have survived
and in an emotional moment duron curses
his father for shutting down the entire
vein something although perilous could
bring them unimaginable wealth elrond
tells his friend not to be quick to
anger unlike himself durran still has a
father enjoy the time you have with him
because you never know when it'll be
gone elrond's father was lifted beyond
the bounds of this world by the valar
for his work in vanquishing morgoth and
that's the last he ever saw of him after
he's cooled down durn apologizes to his
father realizing he was right it is
better to put the safety of his people
above the pursuit of riches how long
this will last well we'll see because
nothing is said about the reign of
during the fourth however we do know
that during the six continues the mining
of mithril in kazadoom so sometime
between now and the reign of during the
six mining for mithril begins once again
the king and prince both believe the
elves are up to something so the king
tasked the prince with going to linden
to find out what this is aerondir brings
with him adar's ominous message that the
people may live if they forsake all
claim to these lands and swear fealty to
him should they choose not to accept
that they will be coming for osterith
the elven outpost where they currently
reside meanwhile waldrick tells theo
about the sword that it's not a sword
but a power fashion for their ancestors
by sauron's own hand remember that these
southlanders were once aligned with
sauron's master morgoth hence why the
elves built these outposts to keep tabs
on them waldrig also believes that
meteor that passed a few nights ago was
sauron returning if that's true does
that mean the stranger is sauron could
there be multiple meteors the sauron
meteor theory suggests that adar is a
servant and not sauron himself i'll
probably shoot myself for saying this
but i currently believe sauron is not
the stranger nor adar watch i'll be
proven wrong next episode speaking of
adar he's told by an orc that they found
it it's likely referring to theo's sword
it's all the more reason for adar to
send his troops toward the outpost the
numenoreans have gathered to watch
galadriel's departure it's been decades
since the nelf was here who knows how
much longer before they see another and
as galadriel departs the queen makes her
way back to the court when nymeloth's
petals reign upon her not just one petal
but hundreds both ellendile and muriel
share a look like oh this can't be good
notice that hal brandt has made it out
of jail was it our pharaoh's on who let
him out how did this happen and the
queen takes a big gamble a compromise
that may appease the people while
allowing her to venture to middle earth
and see if it's true that the dark lord
has returned she will personally escort
galadriel back and aid their besieged
brethren in the southlands taking any
who wish to prove their valor among them
as part of an expeditionary force in her
speech there's no mention of forging any
alliance with the elves plus it gets rid
of galadriel so it seems to be a win-win
this will likely put our farazon in
charge while she's away which raises a
major red flags for me considering how
much of a schemer he seems to be the
ships will leave in 10 days and both
easeldor and his friends agree to join
this force isildor has always yearned to
travel to middle earth where it was
hinted his brother anarion lives now if
you want to see where the show may be
handed in the episodes to come this is
your warning for the book and trailer
spoiler section i won't be going over
every shot found in the trailers just
the stuff i think may be relevant for
next episode well it looks like
galadriel leaves with her expeditionary
force and is on her way to middle earth
they have 10 days to repair so whether
they leave right away or if it takes
some time remains to be seen we went an
entire episode without the harfoot
storyline so i imagine we'll get a lot
more from them next episode we'll see
the stranger fend off a group of wolves
protecting nori and her family here's a
giant flock of what i think are orcs
since the next shot is of a dar in front
of his ark army this might be them
preparing for their attack on osterith
and it looks like prince durran will be
making it to linden for that meeting
with king gilgalad hoping to find out
what the elves are planning hallbrand
asks galadriel why she continues to
fight she is likely wanting him to join
her to middle-earth something he does
not wish to do he said countless times
he wishes to remain in numenor likely
because something haunts him back home
we do see that he eventually gets some
sweet new armor and kicks some ass with
galadriel in middle-earth interesting to
note that there are no images of queen
muriel at all in middle-earth here we
see that expedition force invading the
orc-held town of tierrat where theo and
bronwyn are from we can see waldrig's
tavern here and there are a ton of
arrows on the roof so it looks like this
is some sort of big assault here's
aorion a bit tearful as the soldiers
make their way onto the ships to leave
numenor of course she's sad because now
both her brothers will have left her
isildor in the middle of battle it looks
as though he's made it across the sea a
ship explodes in what appears to be the
numenor harbor it's just a gut feeling
that this could be some sort of
assassination attempt on either
galadriel or the queen or just maybe
someone who does not want this
expeditionary force to leave this shot
of galadriel alongside her expeditionary
force is either the takeover of
tiraharad or a battle down the line i
also wonder if this shot of her recovery
in this destructive ashen waste is from
this battle or something else later on
in the third trailer we see this image
of the expeditionary forces and tier
herad townspeople celebrating what might
be their victory however this huge
explosion happens there's a brief shot
of galadriel closing her eyes with
embers flying around her this looks like
it could be linked to that destruction
shot arandir has infiltrated the tower
where a group of orcs with torches have
gathered maybe this is some sort of trap
they've devised as we see a bunch of
orcs completely decimated by a landslide
of rocks notice here that dear is
wearing his elven watch armor the same
armor that was taken off that orc does
he get it back somehow or is this just a
spare laying around check out this juicy
image of orcs ascending the tower
leading them as a dar but look who's
beside him it appears to be waldrig it
looks like he's turned sides promising a
dar he knows where he can find that
sword now one of the trailers also shows
a balrog in the books it's king during
the six who unknowingly awakens the
slumbering balrog within kazadoom while
venturing deeper for mithril i wonder if
they'll change this for the show to link
it up with during the force mithril find
that would make a lot more sense than
just having a random balrog appear it's
this balrog that eventually leads to all
the doors having to abandoned kazadoon
but now i leave it to you what are your
thoughts about this episode and what do
you think will happen next thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
think story yt until next time remember